GOOD MORNING.
THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE FLOOR CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY
ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES SAYS
CHAU CHAVEZ.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DIAL THE. DAILY.
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY. GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TEAM VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS NOW PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THIS MORNING'S PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND BOB OSHITA READINESS
TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE EVENTS OF OUR WORLD.
AND OUR NATION HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
IN CONSTANT FLUX.
AND TO THE CHANGES HOWEVER WE
MAY JUDGE THEM.
ONE THING CONTINUE TO REMAIN
CONSTANT.
WE HUMAN BEINGS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
EVOLVING. BECOMING AND HOPING
FOR A BETTER LIFE.
FOR THE MIGRATION OF THE
ANCESTORS OF THE NATIVE
AMERICANS.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
THROUGH THE WAVES OF IMMIGRANTS
THAT CAME TO THIS LAND FROM PRE
COLONIAL TIMES.
UP UNTIL NOW.
THOSE THAT HAVE WANTED TO MAKE
AMERICA THEIR HOME.
CAME HOPING AND QUIETLY
DREAMING.
OF A BETTER LIFE.
THE UNITED STATES HAS BEEN A
NATION OF HOPEFUL IMMIGRANTS AND
DREAMERS.
EACH WAVE CHALLENGED BY THOSE
FEARING CHANGE.
EACH GENERATION TRYING TO
OVERCOME THE BARRIERS THAT
PREVENTED THEIR INCLUSION.
EVEN THROUGH TIMES OF TREMENDOUS
ADVERSITY. AMERICA HAS REMAINED
A DREAM IN PROGRESS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
CHALLENGED BY THOSE FEARING
CHANGE AND DIVERSITY.
BUT WITH THE STRENGTH OF
HUMANKIND.
WE CAN EMBRACE OUR SHARED
HUMANITY. AND TOGETHER KEEP
ALIVE THAT DREAM OF A MORE
PERFECT UNION.
NOW MORE ME.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU EVER NATIONAL. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AS HE LEADS US IN THIS
MORNING'S PLEDGE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
EASILY MET AT SEVEN A. M. ON
IRAQI DAY CHAVEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVENTY SIX DISTRICT PRESIDING.
YOU COULD EAT OUT THE WHOLE
THING AT THE DESK READING QUICK
KATHLEEN LUIS READING THE BONTA
PLACED UPON THE MORNING ROLL
CALL ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY
ARAMBULA BAKER BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM. BONTA BROUGH BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS A MISTER DALI SECONDS THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTIONS AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
AND.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
THAT'S IS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
ABSENCES
NOTE. I MISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KEVIN MULLIN ON PATERNALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN IS AREA
ATTORNEY LEAVE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELISSA MELENDEZ OUR
EXCUSE FOR ILLNESS.
SCOTT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON THURMAN TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SOMEONE.
BLOOM
COOPER AND STEINORTH JUST.
GERMAN IMAGE
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW SOMEONE TO.
TO TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BUDGET
COMMITTEE BILLS TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE.
OF CONCURRENCE AB ONE OF FIVE
AB ONE OF SIX AB ONE AWAY NEED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
MS I YOUR CURRENT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I'M SO PROUD TO INTRODUCE THREE
OF MY INTERNS WHO ARE VISITING
THE CAPITOL TODAY THEY ARE HERE
IN THE GALLERY YOU WANNA PLEASE
STAND UP GIRLS.
JUST STEAM MEDINA ASHLEY LUGO
AND LAUREN TO CARLO WORKED IN MY
DAVIS DISTRICT OFFICE AT THE END
OF LAST YEAR WHEN THE WILDFIRES
HIT THE NORTH BAY.
WELL ALL OF MY AMP IT IN TURNS
TO AN INCREDIBLE JOB THESE THREE
WERE REALLY ASKED TO GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE CALL OF DUTY.
THEY WERE INSTRUMENTAL PART OF
MY TEAM DURING THE WILD FOR A
RESPONSE.
HELPING ANSWER PHONES PROVIDING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE INFORMATION
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE PEOPLE
IN OUR DISTRICT FELT SAFE AND
COMFORTED.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME THESE
WONDERFUL WOMEN WHO SPENT HOURS
AND HOURS.
OF THEIR TIME AND GAVE THEIR
HEART AND SOUL TO OUR.
NOR THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
YOUR HARD WORK
OUR MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
A MEMBERS.
SECOND READING.
CLICK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX WITH THEM AND THEN.
ALL.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
.
QUICKLY SENATORS FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
RELATIVE TO SCHOOL BREAKFAST
WEEK.
THIS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TO REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT I
MAY SEE ART ONE EIGHTY SIX TO
DECLARE THIS WEEK AT SCHOOL
BREAKFAST WEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN I WAS A TEACHER I REGULARLY
SAW STUDENTS COMING TO SCHOOL
WITHOUT HAVING BREAKFAST.
WHICH MADE IT EVEN HARDER FOR
THEM TO CONCENTRATE IN THE
CLASSROOM. STUDIES SHOW THAT ONE
IN FIVE KIDS REALLY GOING OUT.
THAT IS AS YOU KNOW MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO HIS RUBIO FOR HER
PRESENTATION.
ISRAEL PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU WHEN I WAS A TEACHER I
REGULARLY SAW STUDENTS COMING TO
SCHOOL WITHOUT HAVING BREAKFAST
WHICH MADE IT EVEN HARDER FOR
THEM TO CONCENTRATE IN THE
CLASSROOM.
STUDIES SHOW THAT ONE IN FIVE
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA FACE HUNGER
EVERYDAY.
SCHOOL BREAKFAST IS INVALUABLE
TO NOT ONLY FIGHT CHILD HUNGER
BUT TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
STUDENTS WHO EAT SCHOOL
BREAKFAST ATTEND AN AVERAGE OF
ONE POINT FIVE MORE DAYS OF
SCHOOL PER YEAR.
SCORE SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
PERCENT HIGHER ON MATH TESTS
AND I TWENTY PERCENT MORE LIKELY
TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL.
IN MY DISTRICT THE ALMIGHTY
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH HAVE A
VERY HIGH POPULATION OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH A NO KATE THE HUNGRY
CAMPAIGN.
TO IMPLEMENT UNIVERSAL BREAKFAST
PROGRAMS SO THAT EVERY STUDENT
IN THE DISTRICT IN START THE DAY
WITH A NUTRITIOUS MEAL. AS A
RESULT ABOUT NINETY ONE PERCENT
OF THE STUDENTS IN THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE EATING BREAKFAST ON
CAMPUS.
PROVIDING THESE KIDS WHO MAY BE
FACING FOOD INSECURITY WITH A
HEALTHY BREAKFAST OPTION IN THE
MORNING.
ACR ONE EIGHTY SIX OF THE
MEASURE TO RAISE AWARENESS OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING ACCESS.
TO PROPER NUTRITION ACCESS TO
MEALS AND INCREASE PARTICIPATION
IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'D LIKE TO.
HAVE THE FIRST WILL OPEN FOR
COOPERS.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
THIS RUBIOHAS ASKED FOR CO
AUTHORS FOR HER RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
QUICKOFFICE.
MEMBERS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLINTON CLOSE THE ROLE.
WE WERE AT FIFTY SIX CO AUTHORS.
WILL MOVE THROUGH A VOICE VOTE
ON THIS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE.
ANY OPPOSED.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
IN THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE MOVED FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN.
QUICK PLEASE INTRODUCE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE BY
SOME THE MEMBER RAY AS RELATIVE
TO INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK.
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU H. R.
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH DECLARES A
SECOND WEEK OF MARCH AS
INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK.
ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL RICH
AND DYNAMIC ASPECTS OF
CALIFORNIA IS IT'S DIVERSE CITY.
THIS INCLUDES WHERE WE COME
FROM.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE SPEAK AND
ULTIMATELY WHO OR WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN.
DIVERSE CITY A PERSPECTIVES IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO WHO WE ARE AS A
STATE.
AND THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES
THE WIDE ARRAY OF RELIGIOUS
FAITHS AND CREEDS
PRACTICED BY ALL CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY REPORTS OF ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE REPORTS BY ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE ACLU AND CARE INDICATOR
RISE IN HATE CRIMES AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST RELIGIOUS
MINORITIES ACROSS THE NATION.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THIS THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER.
WE MAKE CLEAR THAT WE RECOGNIZE
CELEBRATE AND PROTECT OVER OUR
RELIGIOUS DIVERSITY.
INTERFAITH AWARENESS NOT ONLY
CELEBRATES RESPECTIVE RELIGIONS.
FAITHS AND CREEDS BUT ALSO THE
BEAUTY IN THEIR CO EXISTENCE
AND THE POWER AND SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE CIVIL SERVICE THEY
PERFORM. FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
FAITH LET ORGANIZATIONS.
S. ME OF NUMEROUS PERSPECTIVES
PROVIDE VITAL SERVICES AND
OPERATE AS A STAPLE OF MANY
COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
EMPOWERING INDIVIDUALS TO REACH
THEIR TRUE POTENTIAL.
INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK ALSO
OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DIALOGUE.
I ENCOURAGE DURING THIS WEEK
THAT WE ALL TAKE OPPORTUNITIES
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT OTHER FAITHS
AND PERSPECTIVES.
AS THIS COULD NOT ONLY LEADS TO
A GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TRUTHS OF OTHERS. WHAT OUR OWN
AS WELL?
LET US CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSIVITY. IT IS
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE AN AYE
VOTE AND ALSO THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
AS A MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY AYE RISE AS
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT. OF HR EIGHTY FIVE AN
INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO OUR STANDING. AS
A LEADER IN THE WORLD
CELEBRATION OF INTER FAITH
ACTIVITIES AND DIALOGUES NOT
ONLY SUPPORTS THE RICH
AND DIVERSE FAITHS REPRESENTED
ACROSS OUR STATE BUT WEEKS LIKE.
INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK HELP
US ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE STATE
ARE CONTINUING. OUR TRADITION OF
CELEBRATING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSIVITY DESPITE THE RISE IN
HATE CRIMES
THAT WAS SEEN BASED ON ONE'S
RELIGION. OR FAITH
THIS IS INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
AS WE CONTINUE TO HEAR THE DOT
DIVISIVE RHETORIC WHICH
ALIENATES RELIGIOUS MINORITIES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR HR EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA. DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF OF AGE
OF OF OF THIS RESOLUTION.
THIS WEEK BECAUSE HR EIGHTY FIVE
AND THE INTERFAITH AWARENESS
WEEK.
ON BEHALF OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
OF THE CONGRESSIONAL BECAUSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
WE SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND
IT'S INTERESTING IF WE THINK
ABOUT IT OF ALL THE NATIONS IN
THE WORLD.
ALL THE NATIONS IN THE WORLD WE
SHOULD BASICALLY CELEBRATE THIS
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE.
BECAUSE WE'RE A NATION THAT'S
FOUNDED ON THE CONCEPT OF
RELIGIOUS DIVERSITY.
WE'RE A NATION THAT CAME INTO
EXISTENCE BECAUSE OF THE
REPRESSION OF OTHERS WITH
CONCERNING RELIGION.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE IN OUR MOTTO
THAT WE ARE A NATION UNDER GOD.
THAT WE HAVE ON OUR MONEY IN GOD
WE TRUST.
AND SO WE HAVE BASICALLY PUT IN
EVERY SYMBOL THAT WE HAVE THE
IMPORTANCE OF GOT. THE
IMPORTANCE OF RELIGION IN
IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSITY OF THAT
RELIGION.
AND YET WE KNOW TOO OFTEN THAT
IS THAT SAME WAY IN WHICH THAT
RELIGION HAS BEEN A GUIDING
FORCE AND A SUPPORT FOR
DIVERSITY. IT HAS ALSO BEEN USED
TO BASICALLY DIVIDE AND TO
CONQUER AND TO DESTROY.
NO WILL PROBABLY RECOGNIZES THAT
MORE THAN AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO NOT ONLY WERE IN SLAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY BY THE POWER OF THE
GOVERNMENT. BUT ALSO BY THE
POWER OF THE RELIGION.
THAT WHEN WE FOUGHT AGAINST
SEGREGATION IN THE SOUTH IT WAS
A REAL BASICALLY THE WHITE
CITIZENS COUNCIL IN THE VARIOUS
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
FORMED AND SUPPORTED THE
SEGREGATION.
WHEN WE FOUGHT AGAINST THE IN OF
FOR INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS AND
WAS SCHOOLS WERE SHUT DOWN IN
ARKANSAS AND VIRGINIA FOR AN
ENTIRE YEAR. IT WAS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ACTUALLY
OPENED UP WHITE ONLY SCHOOLS IN
THE SOUTH TO MAKE SURE THAT MY
CHILDREN DID NOT YOU LOSE A YEAR
OF EDUCATION.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT RELIGION
WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS A
POWERFUL FORCE AND IT IS ALSO
ALWAYS BEEN A POWERFUL FORCE IN
THE LIFE OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
WHO BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE POWER OF RIGHT THEY
COULD OVER ON THEY COULD
OVERCOME AN ARMY OF EVIL? AND AS
A RESULT OF THAT THEY USE THEIR
RELIGION TO STRENGTHEN THEM AND
TO PUSH FORWARD IN THE ISSUES
THAT WERE MOST IMPORTANT. AND SO
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE THE POWER OF
RELIGION TO DO GOOD.
BEGIN A FAITH THAT WE NEED TO
BASICALLY LOOK AT IT AS OUR
STRENGTH AND OUR SUPPORT. AND
ALWAYS GUARD AGAINST THE ALSO
THE POWER OF RELIGION TO DO
EVIL.
WE RECOGNIZE THIS IS OUR INTER
FAITH WEEK THAT SHOULD PROMOTE
MORE DIVERSITY MORE CONVERSATION
WILL UNDERSTANDING AND TO GIVE
US THE VALUES THAT WE NEED TO
BASICALLY CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN
THIS NATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU AYE VOTE FOR HR EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WEBER SOME IN RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS.
SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY FIVE.
CALIFORNIA IS A UNIQUE IN ITS
ABUNDANCE OF CULTURES FACE AND
BELIEFS.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE CELEBRATE OUR DIVERSITY
AND ENSURE THAT PEOPLE OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS FEEL SAFE IN OUR
STATE.
AS A STATE WE MUST CONTINUE
FIGHTING AGAINST INJUSTICE AND
INEQUALITY.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS WHY
INTERFAITH ASSOCIATIONS ARE
IMPERATIVE.
TO THE MAKE UP OF CALIFORNIA.
THE INCLUSIVENESS OF PEOPLE OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS IS WHAT WE
STRIVE FOR WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
THE BEST STATE OF THE UNION.
I WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SOMEBODY YOU KNOW FOR BRING THIS
MEASURE FORT AS I TRULY BELIEVE
IN THE SIGNIFICANCE. OF
RECOGNIZING OUR STATE'S
DIVERSITY MEMBERS ARE STRUCK THE
HOUSE FOR A VOTE. ON HR EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SOME OF IRAN'S IS ASKING FOR
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE CAN TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
DIES OUT IN THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED
.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL RETURN A
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE
UP THE BUDGET BILLS.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FIVE PLEASE
INTRODUCE.
LOCAL READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OF
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY TO THE STATE BUDGET
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BUDGET BELL.
IS A MEMBER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE OH FIVE IS
IDENTICAL TO S. B. ONE SIXTEEN.
JUST WHAT WE HEARD IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE EARLIER. THIS WEEK I
THIS BILL AMENDS THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT CLARIFIED
THAT THE STATE ITSELF CAN SPEND
A PORTION OF THE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING. WE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR CENSUS OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES IN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
UP.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T.
THANK YOU MISTER KING CENA FOR
THE DEBATE.
CLICK WELL BELOW.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW TO VOTE.
I SIX SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
CONCURRED.
WILL MOVE DOWN TO S. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OF SIX LOCAL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OF SIX BY
I COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY TO CANNABIS MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY FELT REALLY
TO THE BUDGET.
VISITING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER AB ONE OH
SIX IS IDENTICAL TO S. B. ONE
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS.
CLEAN UP TO OUR CANNABIS TRAILER
BILL THE BILL CONTAINS LANGUAGE
RELATED TO CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS REQUESTED BY DOJ. TO
RESPOND THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE
FBI.
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
RESOLVING THIS ISSUE WILL ALLOW
THE ISSUANCE OF PERMANENT
LICENSES.
A CANNABIS CULTIVATORS.
THIS BILL ALSO APPROPRIATE TEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR RADIO
FREQUENCY IDENTIFICATION TAGS.
BEGIN THE ELECTRONIC TRACK
INTEREST SYSTEM.
BUT IN ADDITION THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
MONTHLY MEETINGS TO UPDATE
MEMBERS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION.
PROP SIXTY FOUR SO WE CAN
CONTINUE OVERSIGHT OF THIS
IMPORTANT POLICY CHANGE.
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER KING AS A
MEMBER LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY. THE ADMINISTRATION'S MADE
A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF GETTING ALL
TRANSACTIONS.
CAPTURED WITHIN THE TRACK AND
TRACE PROGRAM.
IT'S QUICK YOU QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
TRACK IT TRACES THE BACKBONE OF
THIS REGULATORY SYSTEM AND
WITHOUT IT. WE RUN THE RISK OF
FAILURE OF THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO PASS THIS BILL NOW
DUE. TO ALLOW THE BACKGROUND
CHECK PROCESS FOR LICENSEES TO
GET STARTED WITH THAT FBI.
NO WILL ALL TEMPORARY LICENSE
HOLDERS TO APPLY TO RECEIVE
THEIR ANNUAL LICENSES.
AND IN TURN BEGIN REPORTING INTO
THE TRACK AND TRACE SYSTEM.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE VAULT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LOCAL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES AYE SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS
ONE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
CAN HEARD.
MOVED ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NO EIGHT
COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL WANNA EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACTUALLY
THE EDUCATION MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
A SIMILAR TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY BILL ONE AWAY
THE TENTACLED SP ONE TWENTY ONE
WHICH IS AN AMENDMENT TO OUR
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL. BILL
MOVES FUNDING FOR THE EVERY KID
COUNTS COLLEGE SAVINGS PROGRAM
BUT THE TREASURER'S OFFICE TO
THE STUDENT EIGHT COMMISSION.
ALSO CONSOLIDATE THE STATUTORY
PROVISIONS RELATED TO VARIOUS
COUNTY CHILDCARE. BILL PILOTS.
NOW ALLOW CD TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATED IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
THESE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS LATER
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROCESS.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER KING SEEN
HEARING NO ADDITIONAL DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLIED THE VOTE.
I THINK SIXTY FORD KNOWS ZERO.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
PINKERTON.
CLICK PLEASE ENTITIES AB A BILL
ONE TEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACTUALLY
THE GOVERNMENT SERVICES MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECTIVE ILLEGAL RELIGIOUS
BUDGET.
MISTER TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TEN IS
IDENTICAL TO SP ONE TWENTY.
WHICH A MAN'S THE GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL THAT WE PASSED
EARLIER THIS YEAR OR BURKE. OF
EARLIER LAST YEAR. I HAD THE
BILL SEVEN IMPORTANT PROVISIONS
INCLUDING AYE HELPS FOSTER
PARENTS GET THE PAYMENTS THEY
ARE OWED. CLARIFIES SOME OF THE
PROVISION RELATED TO THE I JUST
AS PROGRAM RELATED TO ACTIONS WE
TOOK IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUDGET. AND LASTLY EXEMPTS
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE RECORDING
FEES CREATED IN LAST YEAR'S S.
B. TO.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FRIDAY.
THANK YOU MISTER KING SEEN
HEARING NO ADDITIONAL DEBATE
QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW TO VOTE AYE SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ONE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS RETURN TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
ITEMS TWO THROUGH FIVE WILL BE
CONTINUED.
ITEM SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT WILL BE
PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US NOT A FILE ITEM
ELEVEN CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE
TO PRICE ONLY MEMBER BAKER
RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK.
A MEMBER BAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY ACR ONE EIGHTY TWO.
TODAY WE ARE COMMEMORATING THE
WEEK OF MARCH FOURTH THROUGH
MARCH TENTH AS WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK AND IT IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY. TO NOT ONLY
IDENTIFY HIGHLIGHTED CELEBRATE
THE ROLE THAT WOMEN PLAY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BUT THE.
CONTINUED PROGRESS THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CONGRESS DECLARED MARCH AS THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
IN PERPETUITY AND SPECIFICALLY
THIS WEEK TO BE DESIGNATED WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION WEAK. AND THE
ROLE THAT WOMEN PLAY NOT ONLY IN
CONSTRUCTION OWNERSHIP
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND BUILDING
AND DESIGN AND ENGINEERING BUT
ALSO IN THE CRITICAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT ARE
IN CONSTRUCTION. CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW
HAS A TREMENDOUS NEED FOR
SKILLED AND MOTIVATED WORKERS
MANAGERS ENTREPRENEURS AND
CONSTRUCTION BUSINESS OWNERS
WOMEN EXCEL AT FILLING THAT
NEED.
AN APPRENTICESHIP IS A CRITICAL
PATH WAY FOR WOMEN TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE AND EQUALLY IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING ECONOMY.
RISING COSTS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AND INVOLVING EMPLOYER WORKFORCE
TRAINING. THESE NEEDS MAKE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT AND THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN EMPLOYED IN THE
U. S. CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY HAS
GROWN BY EIGHTY THREE PERCENT.
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN ALONE.
AND FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TO
TWENTY TEN HOWEVER WHEN THE
ECONOMY WAS SO SLOW WE LOST OVER
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
CONSTRUCTION JOB MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND WOMEN
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA LEFT THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. AS A
RESULT OF THAT SLOWDOWN IN THE
NUMBER BY TWENTY TEN WAS ONLY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
WOMEN. AND ACCURATE ACCORDING TO
THE BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN APPROXIMATELY
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE WOMEN
ARE BACK IN GETTING INTO THE
OCCUPATIONS THAT ARE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
BUT WOMEN CURRENTLY OCCUPY ONLY
TEN PERCENT OF APPRENTICESHIPS
AND MAKE UP ONLY NINE PERCENT OF
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
NATIONWIDE. AS A STATE WE SHOULD
SUPPORT EFFORTS FOR THERE TO BE
MORE WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION THEY
ARE GREAT AT IT.
THE WORK FORCE IN CALIFORNIA IT
NEEDS IT IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE. THAT
CONSTRUCTION PATHWAYS TO YOUNG
STUDENTS AND GIRLS IN SCHOOL
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT STEM.
AND STEM JOBS AND GIRLS IN STEM
REMEMBER THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IF YOU HAVE EVER OF A
BIT VISITED.
IN A PRESS APPRENTICE SHOP.
AND YOU SEEN THE TRAINING THEY
DO OUR LOOK AT THE MANUALS LOOK
AT THE MATH BOOKS THAT THEIR
USING LOOK AT THE MASS THAT IS
USED ALL THROUGHOUT THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IT'S MUCH
BETTER MATH THAN I CAN DO. AND
WOMEN ARE GREAT AT IT THEY'RE
TEACHING THOSE CLASSES IN THE
APPRENTICE SHOPS AND THEY'RE
ALSO DOING THE WORK THESE ARE
GREAT STEM JOBS THAT WE NEED TO
BE PROMOTING IN CALIFORNIA. AND
SO COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME TODAY IN CELEBRATING WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION AND IN THE WORK
THAT WE DO TOGETHER TO CONTINUE
OPEN THOSE PATHWAYS FOR SUCCESS
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP. AND
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS GREAT
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND ALSO ASK.
FOR CO AUTHORS AS WELL AND
THINK THE.
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS FOR
BEING A PART OF THIS RESOLUTION
AND ALL THE LEADERSHIP THAT THEY
HAVE SHOWN AND SUPPORT FOR WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
SEEN IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAKER HAS ASKED FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND.
THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS.
WE'LL DO A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT IN THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THE MEMBER BAKER HAS SOME
INTERACTIONS
YOU THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
VERY PROUD TO WELCOME AND
RECOGNIZED GUESTS WE HAVE IN THE
GALLERY.
WE HAVE FROM THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE
PRESIDENT DEVRY SHRUM AND
PRESIDENT ELECT KELLY CAO AND.
WE ALSO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS BUILDER
EXCHANGES ASSOCIATED BUILDERS
AND CONTRACTORS NOR CAL
INSTRUCTORS AND NATIONAL CENTER
FOR CONSTRUCTION EDUCATION
RESEARCH CHRISTINE LEN.
ALSO A. B. C. NOR CAL PRESIDENT
MICHELLE DOUGHERTY AND A. B. C.
NOR CAL VICE PRESIDENT OF
EDUCATION OUTREACH REMEMBER
THOSE DAMN JOBS I TOLD YOU ABOUT
AND QUICK. IN ALSO ENTERED
INTEGRITYAIR SYSTEMS
CORPORATION FROM HAYWARD SUSAN
SIEGERT PLEASE WELCOME OUR GREAT
GUESTS WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION IN
THE INDUSTRY
.
MEMBERS THE REMAINING ITEMS WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN.
WE'LL GO BACK FOR ADDITIONAL
INTRODUCTIONS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
BUT MISTER MULLINS DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A SPECIAL PRIVILEGE
TO RECOGNIZE SISTER GET THINK
ASK YOU TO PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU TO DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION MR GIPSON FOR HIS
IMPORTANT REDUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
SPECIAL PRIVILEGE TO RECOGNIZE
AN INDIVIDUAL.
THAT IS.
STANDING WITH ME I'VE BEEN
KNOWING HIM FOR MANY MANY YEARS
I'M HERE IS THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND A
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE'S. PRESIDENT
OF.
PRESIDENT WILLIE J. HAGEN DOCTOR
HAGEN WILL BE STEPPING DOWN AS
PRESIDENT THIS JUNE. OF THIS
YEAR WE ALSO HE ALSO HAVE
MEMBERS AND THE GALLERY OF HIS
TEAM WHO'S JOINING THEM.
SINCE HE WAS APPOINTED AND TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE AYE HE HAS
DELIVERED ON MANY OF HIS
PROMISES.
ONE OF WHICH IS IMPROVING A
GRADUATION RATE YEAR AFTER YEAR
STRONG IN ROME GAINES A HOUSE
THE UNIVERSE DOMINGUEZ HILLS. UM
IS SPEARHEADING A LAUNCHING STAY
THE ART PROJECT THAT WILL ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF THE COLLEGE OF IS
WELL POSITIONED FOR THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. MORE IMPORTANTLY
DOCTOR HAGEN.
ISN'T ADMIRE.
WELL RESPECTED AS AN EDUCATOR.
IT ALWAYS PUTTING STUDENTS
VERSE UP MEMBERS IT'S THIS IS A
SAD DAY THE WHEN HE LEAVES
CASTING UNIVERSE DOMINGUEZ HILLS
BECAUSE I KNOW OF HIS WORK I
KNOW OF ITS COMMITMENT. AND ALSO
HIS HEART.
FOR THE STUDENTS AND ALSO PUT
ZERO POPULATION THAT SURROUNDS
CAO THE UNIVERSE DOMINGUEZ HILLS
AND SO WE HAVE THIS RESOLUTION
THAT I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF THE RESIDENTS. OF THE
SIXTY FOURTH DISTRICT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I'M WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
A TIRELESS EFFORTS AND YOUR HARD
WORK IN YOUR COMMITMENT TO OF
EDUCATION. AND ALSO TO THE
GENERAL COMMUNITIES THE DOCTOR
HAYGOOD MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME AND THANK DOCTOR HAGEN
FOR HIS YEARS OF SERVICE HARD TO
THE STATE AND TO THE PEOPLE. OF
THE SIXTY FOURTH DISTRICT.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON MISTER
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE.
CALIFORNIA WARM REGARDS TO.
HAGENS ON OCCASION OF HIS
RETIREMENT.
IT CERTAINLY IS A VERY.
SAD DAY AS IT'S POINTED OUT WHEN
YOU HAVE A. A SUPERIOR
ADMINISTRATOR LEADER LIKE DOCTOR
HAGENS YOU DON'T LIKE TO SEE
THEM GO THEIR IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITY AND ALL THE YOUNG
PEOPLE. AT THE UNIVERSITY IS
SECOND TO NONE AND WE APPRECIATE
HIS LEADERSHIP WE ALSO
APPRECIATE HIS LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORTING.
THE BLACK CAUCUS IS EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE OUR AFTER AMERICAN
LEADERS FOR TOMORROW PROGRAM AT
DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND SO. WE HAVE
A A LONG LASTING RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM AND WITH THE UNIVERSITY
AND WE APPRECIATE HIS
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER OF ALL
THE
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS ARE REMINDER THAT WE
WILL HOLD THE ANNUAL WOMEN OF
THE YEAR CEREMONY DURING SESSION
ON MONDAY. GRASS THAT YOU PLEASE
BE PROMPTING YOUR ATTENDANCE.
THE SESSION SAYS SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY MARCH NIGHT NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY MARCH TWELFTH FLOOR
SESSION AT TWO PM NO DE NOTED
LATER TIME FOR THE WOMEN OF THE
YEAR. CEREMONY.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS FOR
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK.
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
YEAH
.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS ARE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS ON THE FLOOR
UP OFF THE FLOOR THE QUORUM CALL
HAS BEEN LIFTED. WE'D LIKE TO
MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS OF OUR GERMAN IT'S IN
MEMORY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
RISE TO ADJOURN AND MEMORY OF A
FRIEND OF MINE STEVEN ROSE.
A CHAMBER OF COMMERCE LEADER A
FORMER MAYOR AND COUNCIL MEMBER
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT COLLEAGUE.
WHO I HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK
WITH FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS?
ROSE WAS A RESIDENT OF CULVER
CITY FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS AND
WORKED IN THE COMMUNITY AS A
BUSINESS OWNER AND PUBLIC
SERVANT.
HE RAN HIS FAMILY'S UPHOLSTERY
STORE PRIOR TO JOINING THE
CULVER CITY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AS ITS PRESIDENT AND CEO WHERE
HE WORKED FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
ROSE WAS ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN CULVER CITY IN TWO
THOUSAND WHERE HE SERVED UNTIL
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. SERVING AS
ITS MAYOR FROM TWO THOUSAND
FORTY TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
AS A MEMBER OF THE COUNCIL HE
WORKED ON A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES INCLUDING THE
REVITALIZATION OF DOWNTOWN.
CULVER CITY.
WHICH UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP. HAS
BECOME A WALKABLE AND WELL KNOWN
REGIONAL DESTINATION.
AS A MEMBER OF THE COUNCIL ROSE
WAS ALWAYS KNOWN FOR BEING FAIR
AND JUDICIOUS.
HE BELIEVED THAT THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE SHOULD ADVOCATE FOR
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS BUSINESS
AND TRUSTS.
AND THAT PHILOSOPHY UNDERSCORED
MUCH OF HIS WORK.
ROSE RETIRED LAST JUNE FROM THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE'S BOARD. OF
DIRECTORS AND PASSED AWAY ON
MONDAY FOLLOWING A BRIEF BATTLE
WITH LEUKEMIA AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
MISTER STEINORTH. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO JOIN IN
ADJOURNMENT OF MEMORY IN FAITH
IN MEMORY OF MASTER SERGEANT
DELP PICK ME.
WE LOST DEL SUDDENLY TO A HEART
ATTACK WHILE HIKING IN THE
CLAREMONT WILDERNESS TRAIL ON
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND.
DEL WAS A SERVANT OF HIS COUNTRY
AND HIS COMMUNITIES ENTIRE ADULT
LIFE HE SPENT THREE YEARS AS THE
UNITED STATES MARINE. FOLLOWED
BY TWENTY NINE YEARS. AND THE
TUSTIN POLICE DEPARTMENT WITH
THE CAREER DECORATED WITH
NUMEROUS AWARDS AND ACCOLADES.
AROUND THE DEPARTMENT HE WAS
NICKNAMED THE ORACLE. BECAUSE HE
SEEMED TO HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
EVERY SOLUTION FOR EVERY PROBLEM
AND AN ANSWER FOR EVERYTHING.
HE WAS A MENTOR TO SO MANY OTHER
YOUNG OFFICERS INCLUDING TYSON'S
CURRENT CHIEF OF POLICE.
DEL TRULY REFLECTED WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE SELFLESS
HIS HEROISM EXTENDED FAR BEYOND
THE FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK. HE WAS
AVAILABLE TO LEND A HAND TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE CALL OF
DUTY. IN ITS OWN TIME HIS STATUS
TO POLICE PROGRAMS THAT WENT
NATIONAL. INCLUDING A SOFTBALL
WORLD SERIES AT ITS RAISE OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
WOUNDED WARRIORS AND FAMILIES OF
FALLEN OFFICERS.
AND THE ADOPT A COMPLEX PROGRAM
WHICH WORKS TO CREATE
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
HE HAS MADE OUR COMMUNITY
EXTREMELY PROUD AND IS LIFE AND
LEGACY WILL BE HONORED FOR YEARS
TO COME.
DELL IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
TWENTY YEARS MICHELLE. AND THEIR
TWO DAUGHTERS RYAN AND RACHEL.
COLLEAGUES I ASKED YOU JOIN MEAN
ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
MASTER SERGEANT DELP PITNEY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STEINORTH.
SOME A MEMBER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS MORNING.
I MEAN DURING THE MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND THEY'LL GROW
ICON ROY HERBERGER.
RIGHT PASSED AWAY RESULT GROWTH
HOME ON MARCH FOURTH HE WAS A
SEVEN YEARS OLD.
WORST OF OUR COUNTRY
DISTINCTION IN THE US AIRFORCE.
AFTERWARDS
HIS WIFE MARY WORKED AS
JOURNALIST IN CALIFORNIA
EVENTUALLY PURCHASE LOGOS THIS
AND IN THE GOAL HAROLD.
OLD ROY.
HE CALLED HIMSELF.
COLUMNS BEEN NEARLY SIXTY YEARS
IF FORMING THE L. GROVER GOAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGH HIS
NEWSPAPERS.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE WHAT HAVE
WE CAMPAIGN TO MERGE SEVERAL
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
ONE UNIFIED DISTRICT.
AS JUDGES FROM FLOOR INTO
WILTON.
SO DISTRICT IS ELK GROVE
UNIFIED.
WERE THE BEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE.
RIGHT WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING ALL GROW GAINFULLY HOOD.
WAS DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND PHILANTHROPY AREN'T
IN THE HONORS THE SIZZLE URINAL
GROVER GOLF AND EVEN A CUE THE
CITY.
WHAT SURVIVE BUYS WIFE AURORA IT
IS CHILDREN DAVID? DEBORAH
ELISABETH.
WE
VANESSA AND SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
TWO GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
MY HEARTFELT PRAYERS GO OUT TO
THE HARBOR FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
HOW TRULY MISSING ROY IN THE
COMMUNITY USE INCREDIBLE MAN?
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEN IN HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BERMAN MOVES MISTER
VOEPEL SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY MARCH TWELFTH AT
TWO PM.
WE'RE JOINED